bonjour à toutes et tous et
bienvenue monsieur le Président
bienvenue
paulem d'abord quelle joie de voir une
assemblée aussi fournie et aussi
qualitative au sein du premier parti
l'alternance pour parler de culture au
cœur d'un projet d'alternance je crois
que c'est déjà une originalité une
singularité et une pertinence qu'il
convient de souligner en introduction de
dire aussi que tous les intervenant des
précédentes tables rondes ont pu le
constater le temps d'intervention est
extrêmement frustrant et on manque
d'interaction mais c'est l'exercice qui
veut cela et pour la dernière table
ronde qui est bien sûr la variable
d'ajustation d'ajustement chronologique
la frustration sera plus grande et je
vous prie par anticipation de bien
vouloir nous en excuser en vous
remerciant de votre participation et et
comme l'a rappelé David erboutin j'ai
j'ai la la la chance d'être délégué
général à la culture et la communication
et je vourrais vraiment saluer le le
travail de qualité qui a été fait par
par l'ensemble des secrétaires nationaux
pour préparer ce contenu programmatique
et et surtout réaffirmer ces principes
de liberté d'expression de singularité
de la France de force de la France par
son rayonnement culturel je crois que
c'est une des spécificités donc dont on
doit être le plus fier et que l'on doit
mettre en exerg dans un projet politique
de gestion de la cité et dans un projet
d'alternance qui doit rimer avec
espérance la culture et certainement le
le premier facteur de cette nouvelle
espérance que l'on doit réussir à bâtir
ensemble alors pour cela et bien il faut
aussi réaffirmer le rôle économique cela
a été évoqué à travers différentes
filières tout à l'heure de la culture
comme catalyseur de création de richesse
comme catalyseur de création de valeur
comme catalyseur d'emploi et au sein de
la culture le patrimoine et le
l'événementiel culturel sont
certainement deux des piliers les plus
moteurs de cette dynamique française
cette dynamique économique la culture
c'est bien sûr ce qui permet à un
individu de de se structurer d'être
souverain d'être indépendant d'être
libre d'être responsable comme le sport
c'est certainement les deux piliers de
l'émancipation individuel la culture
c'est aussi un ciment social c'est un
dénominateur commun et c'est en cela que
c'est essentiel puis la culture c'est
une source de rayonnement international
c'est une source donc de souveraineté de
puissance pour la France et c'est une
source de création d'emploi et au sein
de la culture le patrimoine et
l'événementiel culturel en sont je le
disais les les deux piliers patrimoine
n'en déplaise à à Madame le Ministre de
l'Éducation nationale
l'étymologie l'étymologie sert à
comprendre le sens et et le patrimoine
c'est d'une origine latine sont les
biens de famille la même éologieque dans
patrie évidemment sont les biens de
famille ça VI du père même et vous
remarquerez que la parité n'est pas
vraiment respectée dans ces table ronde
j'anticipa avant avant que tu le dises
voilà donc et à ce titre donc c'est
l'héritage le patrimoine renvoie à une
notion absolument essentielle qu'il faut
redécouvrir que nous devons V porter au
sein des républicains c'est celle de la
transmission d'une verticalité entre les
générations nous sommes les dépositaires
les héritiers d'une histoire d'un
savoir-faire d'une culture et nous
devons les transmettre tout en les
adaptant à la réalité et c'est une des
problématiques que l'on va évoquer à
travers un outil formidable monsieur le
Président merci de votre présence qui
est la Fondation du Patrimoine et qui
permet de mobiliser des moyens pour
sauvegarder et valoriser notre
patrimoine bâti en l'occurrence comment
comment valor
plus qu'il ne l'a été ces dernières
années le patrimoine bâti puisque les
fonds d'État ont fondu sans faire de
mauvais jeu de mots après 2012 et il y a
eu une baisse de 13 % des crédits
consacrés par l'État au patrimoine on
retrouve le niveau de 2012 avec un
artifice d'ailleurs budgétaire mais les
parlementaires savent mieux que moi
puisque de mémoire il y a 100 millions
d'euros qui ont été ajoutés qui
correspondent à l'archéologie préventive
alors que cette archéologie préventive
était hors du périmètre évoqué et
qu'elle a une taxation spécifique qui
bien sûr est capté des désormais par
Bery donc il y a eu une petite un petit
tour de passe-pe budgétaire dont euh
parfois no dirigeants on le le secret en
particulier en ce moment euh le
patrimoine donc comme élément de
valorisation identitaire d'un territoire
comme élément de de sentiment
d'appartenance d'une population à un
territoire que cette population y ait
ses racines ou qu'elle soit plus récente
on doit s'approprier le patrimoine en
être fier le revendiquer et on verra
tout à l'heure je vais pas tout déflorer
qu'il y a des moyens de trouver des
financements privés encore
supplémentaires pour valoriser nos
44000 sites en France qui sont inscrits
d'une façon ou d'une autre au au au
registre des des monuments historiques
donc il y a un enjeu extrêmement fort un
maillage territorial extrêmement fort pu
le patrimoine c'est pas que le
patrimoine matériel c'est le patrimoine
immatériel on l'évoquait sur la musique
on l'évoque dans le cinéma on peut
l'évoquer dans dans l'audiovisuel en
général avec cette exigence de
sauvegarde de ce patrimoine de
numérisation du patrimoine de partage du
patrimoine avec une big data du du hein
du du du patrimoine et donc quelle
solution technique trouvons-nous et
quelle solution budgétaire et et quelle
solution en terme de communication pour
partager ce patrimoine j' en évoquera
l'événementiel culturel euh avec
plusieurs intervenants et je je remercie
Paul zic le PDG de rid Midem qui
organise entre autres le MIP TV le
MIPCOM et et le Midem euh messieur de la
radio euh à CAN qui est manifestation
qu' soutenir c'est le dernier survivant
des grands salons professionnels de
l'industrie musicale et de sur quoi il
est à can donc vous comprenez que je
sois triplement intéressé mais
effectivement merci Paul de cette
présence l'événementiel culturel à
travers les festivals c'est une des
singularités françaises aussi une des
forces de nos territoire et d'une force
de la mise en connexion entre la
création et le public les festivals là
aussi sont un catalyseur de rencontres
et de diffusion mais il n'y a pas que
les festivals il y a toutes les
manifestations business to business pour
parler en bon français les
manifestations professionnelle les
salons professionnels qui font le lien
entre là aussi la création et le marché
et on revient à cette notion de marché
la culture est aussi un élément de
marketing territorial que l'on doit
revendiquer le marketing c'est la
connexion entre une identité et un
marché une identité si on la fossilise
ce que certains de nos compétiteurs voir
adversair politique voudrai faire et
bien on la tu ce qui est fossilisé est
mort nous nous croyons à l'identité
vivante nous croyons à l'identité
ouverte nous cro y à l'identité comme
facteur de prospérité et d'attractivité
c'est ce que permett les le patrimoine
et les les festival culturel que l'on
doit soutenir et qui ont été trop
abandonnés depuis 4 ans en France alors
pour cela je propose d'abord de
commencer cette table rond qui qui qui
en fait est une somme de deux tables
carrées c'est certainement un concept
d'art contemporain avec avec toi
monsieur le ministre avec Renaud
deevabre qui aant fait pour le
rayonnement de la culture et qui à une
fibre culturelle et européenne dont nous
avons tant besoin pour renforcer la
France comme pôle d'excellence
culturelle merci je suis très heureux de
me retrouver dans ma famille politique
qui réaffirme aujourd'hui très
solennellement que la culture n'est pas
une fin de discours élégante mais une
véritable stratégie offensive et je le
dis avec un peu de
gravité le SO des attentats du 13
novembre qui étai des attentats contre
l'art de vivre à la française
c'est-à-dire le vendredi soir ù toutes
les générations que ce soit dans les
matchs de foot dans les concerts dans
les bars dans les restaurant commence un
weekend de manière libre et bien je
trouve tout simplement qu'il a manqué à
la suite de ces attentats l'expression
forte
du fait que la culture dans notre pays
est une liberté et que rien ne sera
jamais
l'atteindre je crois qu'il aurait
fallu une grande
initiative pour que la réponse des
Français ne soit pas uniquement une
manifestation mais une affirmation forte
de nos
valeurs la question aujourd'hui qui est
débattue celle de la culture celle du
patrimoine de l'attractivité c'est
effectivement l'expression de notre
fierté de notre fierté sans arrogance
mais avec
panache parce que nous sommes attendus
sur ces questions il y a des domaines où
nous doutons de nous-mêmes où
effectivement nous sommes remis en cause
et il y a d'autres domaines où nous
sommes attendus partout dans le monde
entier nous n'en avons pas suffisamment
conscience et dans la crise
psychologique que que parfois nous
traversons nous oublions de constater
toutes les forces de création d'histoire
de Racine d'identité de rayonnement qui
sont dans notre pays alors je voudrais
pas être long je voudrais donner
uniquement quelques pistes ou quelques
idées personnelles avec un peu de
nostalgie parce que dans la vie on n pas
toujours le temps de faire ce que l'on a
comme projet je pense que chaque lieu de
notre pays est une chance chaque fermé
chaque lieu qui n'est pas valorisé est
une erreur chaque fois que je passe
devant le Grand Palais je suis un peu le
fantôme du Grand Palais parce que j'en
ai fait la programmation et la
réouverture chaque fois qu'il est fermé
je me dis au fond pourquoi est-ce qu'il
n'est pas ouvert pourquoi est-ce qu'il
n'y aurait pas une initiative du dernier
moment je me souviens il y a quelques
mois de prince qui avait demandé à
assister à un défilé de haute couture
c'est pas très difficile de trouver deux
places pour Prince pour qu'il assiste à
un défilé il découvre la verrière du
Grand Palais il découvre que c'est un
lieu exceptionnel il n'y avait jamais
été il dit à la personne qui était là
est-ce que là on pourrait faire de la
musique au lieu d'avoir une réponse à
lambiqué la personne a regardé son
iPhone et lui a dit samedi et dimanche
prochain si vous voulez c'est possible
il y a eu deux fois 6000 personnes au
Grand Palais pour écouter prince 5 jours
après cette réactivité France
qui est rare elle est un capital que
nous devons réaffirmer chaque lieu
peut-être une chance en ce moment à
titre personnel je travaille sur un lieu
complètement dégradé que 140 millions de
Français connaissent c'est l'axe routier
roissyparis tout simplement pour se dire
que les bas côtés le terrepin central et
le plafond du tunnel du Landi peut-être
une chance de rayonnement artistique
pour les talents pour des artistes pour
des cré Atur dans le domaine des
nouvelles technologies et dans le
domaine de l'art dans son éternité
chaque lieu peut-être une
chance une idée qui a été évoquée pour
les écoles primaires à partir des
orchestres des des éléments du spectacle
vivant je pense que chaque école de
France doit être jumelée avec un lieu de
patrimoine c'est-à-dire qu'il faut que
faire en sorte qu'il y ait des
croisement ce n'est pas vouloir
convaincre et revenir en arrière c'est
tout simplement pour ouvrir l'imaginaire
des jeunes générations faire en sorte
que ces liens se renouent et et ce n'est
pas une vision nostalgique nous avons un
capital entre les mains absolument
considérable il y a Catherine en parlera
j'imagine des métier d'art magnifique
qui travaille pour la restauration de ce
patrimoine ce patrimoine n'est pas une
nostalgie il est aussi la possibilité
d'accueillir des créateurs il y a une
expression que je vous livre parce
qu'elle est lumineuse l'ancien patron de
l'Académie d'architecture Vladimir
Mitrofanov décorant une architecte en
chef des Monuments Historique lui a dit
votre métier n'est pas de conserver mais
de restituer l'énergie initiale je
trouve ça absolument fantastique chacun
dans nos vies dans nos métiers dans nos
passions nous sommes les héritiers de
quelque chose non pas pour contempler
avec tristesse le passé mais tout
simplement pour le faire vivre quand
vous regardez les français et les
Français dans leur diversité
extraordinaire réunie au moment des
journées du patrimoine si je fais de la
provocation ce n'est pas uniquement le
7e arrondissement qui contemple avec
tristesse les évolutions contemporaines
c'est l'emble de nos compatriotes quelle
que soit leur couleur de peau leur
religion de leur vie personnelle qui
sont tout simplement fers de ce que cela
représente pour notre
pays n'est pas un concept uniquement
français c'est aussi un concept européen
j'ai fait partie de ceux qui ont créé le
label européen du patrimoine ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'entre la
fierté de l'UNESCO des monuments
mondiaux et la tradition locale il y a
un espace qui est celui de la vie
concrète de la fierté nous ne la vivons
pas assez aujourd'hui l'Europe est
conçue comme un problème comme une crise
comme des règlements comme des taxes
comme des frontières comme des
difficultés il faut en revenir à ce
qu'on peut appeler la fraternité
européenne cette fraternité européenne
c'est de constater quoi que chez le
voisin c'est aussi beau que chez nous il
faut le faire voir vous parliez tout à
l'heure des budgets colossaux 20
milliards dans les 5 prochaines années
pour l'audiovisuel public je souhaite
qu'il y ait à la télévision dans 28
chaînes de télévision donc sur
l'ensemble de l'Union européenne une
sorte de nuit de la culture européenne
où on passera d'une ville à une autre
d'un lieu à un autre avec à chaque fois
des éléments de musique de cirque de de
distraction qui feront découvrir que à
côté c'est aussi beau que chez nous et
que donc les liens qui sont en train ou
qui ont été constitué
politiquement sur le projet européen
sont en fait des liens de culture et de
civilisation il faut le donner le faire
voir et le faire vivre je crois que
c'est très important je pense et ça
serait une sorte de révolution puisque
ça n'a jamais eu lieu dans l'histoire
européen et peut-être que le le
président de notre mouvement pourrait le
reprendre à son compte qu'il faudrait
qu'il y ait un Conseil européen qui une
fois mettre à son ordre du jour la
question de la culture elle n'a jamais
été d'aucune manière mise à l'ordre du
jour d'un Conseil européen et pourquoi
ne pas traiter des questions de
patrimoine au sens non pas de nostalgie
mais d'affirmation du capital que nous
avons entre les mains dernier point
parce que je sens que je suis déjà trop
long un autre élément très important qui
est au-delà du patrimoine et de la
fierté qui est évidemment le rayonnement
de nos musées de nos collection et de
nos œuvres nous avons décidé
souvenez-vous les critiques que nous
avons eu que j'ai subi lorsque nous
avons lancé le projet du Louvre à Abou
Dhabi il va voir le jour en décembre
prochain dans une conjoncture de
violence de terrorisme d'intégrisme qui
font que le projet politique était déjà
celui-là à l'époque est encore plus
important parce que et bien je crois
tout simplement que dans chaque partie
du monde affirmer les valeurs de notre
culture et de notre civilisation ce
n'est pas l'esprit de croisade c'est
l'esprit tout simplement de paix à
travers la liberté culturelle c'est une
belle conclusion
ça un mot félicitation un mot et je
conclus un mot pour me dire qu'il faut
pas regarder le passé donc le Louvre B
d'ABIT c'est fait je souhaite que la
prochaine équipe se dise au fond
pourquoi pas le Louvre en CHINE
merci
merci magnifique plinnoyer compétent et
quel élan et et surtout l'état d'esprit
que nous partageons patrimoine je vais
passer la parole au président la
Fondation que que je remercie de sa
présence en rappelant l'enjeu on estime
les retombée économique du patrimoine le
patrimoine c'est un élément de
compétitivité d'un territoire pour le
parler de façon très nette à à à plus de
de 21 milliards d'euros et on estime que
l'effet multiplicateur de l'argent
engagé dans le patrimoine est de entre
15 et 20 hein donc on voit bien la
pertinence d'investir dans le patrimoine
vous allez nous le dire plus plus
savemment avec ce ce micro qui est à
votre
disposition euh merci beaucoup euh je
vais juste faire quatre remarques parce
que le patrimoine c'est un sujet si
vaste euh que on pourrait durer un peu
trop longtemps euh sans sans avoir le la
la le brillot et la fougue de de Renault
donie V donc vous vous endormiriez ce
serait dommage donc d'abord un mot la
Fondation du Patrimoine créée par la loi
avec le soutien constant de Jacques
Chirac en 1996 donc
elle a pour but au fond quel est son
objectif son objectif c'est de
conscientiser les français pour parler
comme les curés de gauche en Amérique
latine autrefois de conscientiser les
Français
autour de leur patrimoine de proximité
et de leur dire que le patrimoine de
proximité c'est leur affaire c'est pas
celle de
l'État qui en a d'ailleurs discrètement
profité pour supprimer tout ce qu'
faisait dans ce domaine et et c'est fait
donc il y a pas d'économie là ça n'était
pas 20 milliards c'était quelques
millions mais y a il y a plus d'économie
à faire je regrette ça c'est comme ça
mauvaise nouvelle
donc pour dire je je je vais maintenant
faire un aveu et puis après ça je vais
dire ce qu'on est je chose mon premier
point malheureusement il y a deux choses
que nous sommes pas euh d'abord nous
sommes pas et la loi le prévoit nous
sommes pas sur la
création deuxièmement nous n'avons pas
le problème que vous névoqué par V qu'
les grands monuments nationaux le Louvre
tel qu'il est versaill c'est-à-dire un
choix à faire entre le quantitatif et le
qualitatif choix qui est très délicat
politiquement je rappelle que la gauche
a fait des des des une avancée énorme
politiquement à mon sens sous le grand
Jacques Lang en en en faisant de la
démagogie culturelle c'est-à-dire du
quantitatif à fond en disant tout est
culturel je crois que c'est pas et tout
est création je crois que c'est pas vrai
mais c'est pas notre domaine ça mais
c'est un problème donc nous sommes pas
là-dessus donc voilà ce qui'est la
vocation de la Fondation du Patrimoine
alors maintenant un deuxième remarque
j'en dis pas plus là-dessus qu'est-ce
que c'est que la définition du
patrimoine Monsieur le Maire de carne
c'est pas seulement le bâti puisque nous
soutenons les races animales en
domestique en voie de disparition al
deux prix par an alors la la vache
maréchine la poule du Berry
enfin un chien de
berger dans le Midi enfin on a non non
non on a des truc et et c'est très
intéressant et ça a de la valeur non
quel est pour quelle est la la
définition j'ai dit que c'était pas
quelle est la définition il y a un mot
je crois qu'il n'est pas dans notre
document euh le mot héritage j'ose le le
le le le prononcer ici parce que je
crois que c'est plutôt un mot de droite
que de mot de gauche je suis pas du tout
pour cliver dans le domaine culturel
mais enfin il y a quand même des
différences ben l'héritage nous
l'héritage je crois que c'est un mot
très important mais c'est vrai que je
suis pas très très à gauche doncon
pardon
mais le l'héritage c'est un mot
important et au fond la Fondation du
Patrimoine elle contribue le patrimoine
c'est la partie collectif de l'héritage
c'est la partie qui appartient à tout le
monde en gros et donc c'est c'est c'est
vraiment très important et je crois que
nous pouvons très fortement revantiquer
cela alors j'ai dit qu'on éétait pas
trop sur la
création c'est vrai c'est pas not
voation notre voocation en revanche est
la
transmission la transmission ça a
beaucoup de sens n'est-ce pas d'abord
héritage transmission ça va bien
ensemble mais je ne vais pas demander
ici la suppression des droits de
succession c'est pas du tout mon rôle
euh transmission et et il y a beaucoup
de choses dans dans le programme des
républicains là-dessus dans les idées
des républicains là-dessus euh la
transmission c'est pas seulement la
transmission des bâtiments la
transmission c'est d'abord la
transmission des savoirs euh donc la
relance de l'apprentissage nous avons
reculé dans ce domaine la transmission
des savoirs c'est quelque chose de très
important auquel nous essayons de
contribuer encore une fois je rentre pas
dans le détail euh c'est c'est également
une attention à ce que les normes
nouvelles ne soient pas destructrices
dans ce domaine et dans le domaine du
bâti il y a des grands problèmes dont
nous nous occupons puisque les normes en
matière de bâties sont faites pour la
construction d'avenir c'est tout à fait
normal mais il faut chaque fois prévoir
qu'on respecte aussi la possibilité de
de de maintenir les les les documents de
je vous rappelle que les bâtiments
anciens
théoriquement grâce à l'action des
pouvoirs publics récentes on devrait
tous les emballer dans un dans dans dans
un isolant neuf n'est-ce pas euh euh
c'est peut-être pas forcément une bonne
idée euh bon euh dans ce dans ce domaine
de transmission je signale un problème
sur lequel moi j'ai pas de solution
personne n'a non plus euh parce qu'on a
parlé de la comparaison avec la BBC
n'est-ce pas alors nous on nous parle
souvent du National Trust alors moi je
suis tout à fait pour la comparaison
avec le National Trust n'est-ce pas
c'est très intéressant mais il y a des
petites conditions pour que ça soit
efficace il faut revenir en arrière et
supprimer les invasions à allemande la
Révolution française et cetera si tout
ça n'avait pas eu lieu on pourrait faire
un National Trust à la française la
révolution est donc le Code civil
puisque nachal trust il vit de tout ce
patrimoine existe parce qu'il y a
primogéniture et qu'il n'y a pas eu de
violence
généralisé de depuis 1650 en gros en
Grande-Bretagne ça fait longtemps à
l'exception des visites des employés du
maréchal ging qui finalement sauf à
Coventry ont été là lgement réparé euh
donc nous pouvons pas faire ça et nous
avons donc un gros problème je le dis
simplement c'était ma trè c'était ma
partie transmission nous avons un très
gros problème il y a nous le rappelons
dans dans vous dans le notre dans ce
magnifque dans ce très bon document qui
est là il y a
44000 édifice classé et cetera nous
avons nous aurons un très très gros
problème j'ai j'ai pas la solution hein
de de transmission gestion j'étais
toujours sur ma partie transmission j'ai
pas la solution mais c'est pas la peine
de parler de National Trust parce qu'on
est pas encore une fois sauf à supprimer
le Code civil ce que certains d'entre
nous souhaitent peut-être et revenir à
la primogéniture et enfin je dis un mot
de financement je dis un mot de
financement le C civil fait partie de
notre patrimoine napoléonien donc on con
absolument absolument et et on l'a
d'ailleurs exporté dans beaucoup de pays
euh le
euh euh avant de avant de dire un mot de
financement je me rends compte je n'ai
dans ma premère mon premierre
observation notre vocation
conscientisation je voudrais dire à à
Renaud donie de VAB son idée de jumuler
chaque école peut-être primaire avec
quelque chose à caractère culturel ou
patrimonial bien la Fondation du
patrimoine qui qui a 550 bénévoles sur
le terrain on n'est pas une organisation
de salariés on n'est pas une
administration pourrait tout à fait en
effet faire des propositions dans ce
domaine jouer un rôle actif dans ce
domaine ça paraît une idée très
intéressante euh le parce que c'est bien
d'emmener les gamins au musée du Louvre
mais le patrimoine c'est pas seulement
comment ça c'est là où alors financement
on va pas en parler trop il y a beaucoup
de choses je nous nous proposons dans ce
document un tirage de la Française des
jeux à l'occasion des journées du
patrimoine bien entendu la Fondation du
Patrimoine av voocation ass'y associé
bien entendu dans des conditions à
définir
nous nous avons la Fondation du
Patrimoine je vais vous dire un secret
en réalité on croit que on prend de
l'argent public pour le distribuer au
privé c'est le contraire en réalité on
prend pas mal d'argent privé et on en
met en fait la majorité sur des
bâtiments publics ou associatifs mais je
le dirai à personne bien sûr mais nous
avons un un petit problème de
financement c'est que les successions en
desérance où nous avons un pourcentage
ont brutalement baissé 11 millions en
2014 4 millions en 2016 donc c'est quand
même une baisse assez
brutale nous nous il
faudra vérifier bien que la loi équerte
est appliquée c'est-à-dire que les
comptes en banque en désérance et les
assurances vie en désérance font bien
partie sont bien versés au compte des
successions en désérance et puis s'il y
a plus d'argent bah bien entendu on
débattra de la manière de l'utiliser
mais pour le moment je dis cela parce
que vous allez le constater en 2000
comme toujours c'est c'est sans doute la
seule chose vous allez avoir une
mauvaise surprise en 2017 c'est sûrement
le seul domaine n'est-ce pas
c'est-à-dire l'effet
psychologique c'est tout petit bien sûr
en argent quelques millions mais l'effet
psychologique euh sur le terrain ça va
se ressentir en 2017 nous avons moins
d'argent on va dire on ESP on espaiera
d'avoir d' bonnes surprises en 2017
merci parce que votre patrimoine
chronologique est arrivé à son
terme il a été évoqué plusieurs points
sur le financement effectivement ce que
l'on ressent dans dans nos territoires
et les maires ici présents mes collègues
le savent c'est un attachement très très
fort des habitants au patrimoine et
lorsqu'on croise cet attachement et et
des stratégies d'optimisation fiscale si
on crée des éléments de communication
fort autour du crwfunding avec aussi la
Française des jeux vous l'avez évoqué on
peut vraiment réorienter du financement
privé vers la sauvegarde du patrimoine
et créer du sentiment d'appartenance
catalyser ce sentiment d'appartenance un
mot de nous avons collecté 13 millions
d'euros de financement populaire l'an
dernier à la Fondation du Patrimoine
sur un millier d'opération n'hésitez pas
à l'utiliser pour restaurer la plus
vieille abaye cistercienne de France qui
est sur l'Î le saintonora à CAN et qui
vous sollicite le pour le le le merci
monsieur le Président de le noter le le
patrimoine il faut l'entretenir euh par
par le savoir-faire et et par la
formation par les métiers les métiers
d'art qui sont aussi un élément de
civilisation et de mode de vie et euh
Catherine Duma est l'ardente euh comment
dire défenseur de ces 217 ou 227 métiers
d'art 217 métiers d'art en France merci
beaucoup David bonjour à toutes et à
tous euh en effet comment le patrimoine
euh est une source d'attractivité
touristique alors moi je voudrais
aujourd'hui vous parler du patrimoine
humain du patrimoine des savoir-faire du
patrimoine de la main le savoir-faire de
la main alors je m'exprime aujourd'hui
comme secrétaire national des
républicains devant la Fédération des
métiers d'art que je salue qui est ici
présente qui est une fédération très
active au républicains j'en profite pour
parler du rôle de de ces fédérations
professionnelles euh qui vraiment
celle-ci en tout cas est très très
active euh c'est vrai que euh moi j'ai
cultivé depuis toujours un peu l'amour
de la France David Hervet parlait du
gaulisme tout à l'heure je pense que ce
sont mes racines Gauliste et que j'ai
consacré ma vie euh politique je
consacre ma vie politique à la défense
de de ces patrimoines de ces
savoir-faire de ces métiers d'art euh
parce que c'est très important parce
qu'ils sont présents d'abord sur tout le
territoire euh que chacun peut être
concerné et que c'est une vraie richesse
et qu'on en parle pas assez alors je
remercie vraiment euh ceux qui ont
organisé cette convention d'avoir donné
une place au métier d'art c'est c'est
pas toujours le cas et ça me permet donc
de faire passer ce message alors ces
métiers d'art c'est quoi exactement de
quoi s'agit-il alors il s'agit de 217
métiers d'art David lissenard l'a très
bien dit il s'agit tous les métiers liés
au savoir-faire il s'agit des métiers
d'excellence qui sont donc des métiers
liés à la tradition des métiers de
tradition des métiers liés à la
restauration du patrimoine on en parlait
à l'instant mais aussi et c'est très
important des métiers de création alors
ce sont avant tout des métiers de
passion d'abord je crois que le le fil
d'Arian qui unit l'ensemble de ces
métiers d'art qu'on peut de passer de la
de rure à la haute couture en passant
par la porceline l'art florale et cetera
ils sont très nombreux et très divers ce
fil d'Ariane c'est vraiment la passion
et je voudrais insister auprès de vous
par rapport à leur image parce que loin
de l'image poussiéreuse qu'on peut pe
avoir d'un artisan seul dans son dans
son petit coin dans son atelier on
rencontre aujourd'hui sur notre
territoire en France et c'est une vraie
fierté des hommes et des femmes qui sont
créatifs qui sont dynamiques qui sont
évidemment doués à leur entreprise qui
exportent d'ailleurs dans le monde
entier donc ces métiers sont vraiment
des trésors vivants je reprends le mot
pour désigner les trésors vivants
japonais mais nous en avons aussi en
France des trésors vivants et je dois
vous dire que le monde entier nous les
envies parce que personne dans dans le
monde entier n'a autant et autant autant
de diversité de métiers d'art que la
France alors ces métiers il constituent
aussi la base de l'industrie du luxe
vous savez il n'y a pas d'industrie du
luxe sans la base de ses savoir-faire
c'est même ce qui caractérise
l'industrie du luxe et puis moi je
voudrais aussi ajouter d'autres domaines
d'activités à ces métiers d'art dans un
rapport que j'avais fait quand j'étais
sénatrice je l'avais suggéré euh
et je l'avais suggéré c'est tout le le
secteur de l'art culinaire de la
gastronomie j'ai fait un rapport pour le
Sénat pour inscrire l'ARTC culinaire à
l'Unesco nous avons obtenu cette
reconnaissance UNESCO il est très
important d'ailleurs de travailler à
faire en sorte qu'on puisse la garder et
c'est vrai que la
gastronomieonologie représente
aujourd'hui beaucoup de métiers qui
représente aussi euh le le savoir-faire
français alors deux mots sur les
problématiques évidemment l'image de
métiers il faut contribuer à faire en
sorte que les jeunes se dirigent
beaucoup vers ces métiers mais c'est
plutôt ça se passe plutôt bien il y a un
problème aussi de transmission il y a
des métiers qui sont tellement rares
qu'il y a plus que deux trois personnes
je pense par exemple à la marquetterie
de paille qui les exerc en France donc
nous devons veiller à ce que ces métiers
ne disparaissent pas donc on a tout le
problème de de la formation et il faut
travailler là-dessus je voudrais dire
que ces métiers sont vraiment notre
patrimoine euh sont facteur de
croissance ils contribuent à notre
économie en France mais aussi à l'export
et puis c'est aussi l'image de la France
et là je rejoins le thème de la table
ronde sur l'attractivité touristique
pour finir je voudrais dire qu'il doit
vraiment être la fierté de la France il
faut s'en emparer il faut parler de ce
qui marche en France plusieurs l'ont dit
mais je crois que vraiment là au cas
particulier il faut en parler il faut
faire en sorte peut-être qu'il soit
mieux intégré dans tous les aspects
touristiques par les visites des
ateliers par les parcours aussi circuit
autour du vin et cetera et puis pour
finir je voudrais demander trois choses
peut-être qu'il y ait une convention
spéciale et là je m'adresse à Eric VT
consacrer à ses métiers mais après tout
pas forcément dans le cadre du projet
puisqu'il sera voté le 2 juillet mais
plus tard je pense que ça vaut le coup
qu'on puisse vraiment parler de tout ce
qui fait l'excellence française qu'on
lève ce tabou je voudrais également dire
que je m'adresse là au prochains
candidats à la présidentielle alors pour
l'instant il y en a pas dans la salle
mais je pense qu'on transmettra le
message les Français ont envie qu'on
leur parle de ce qui marche bien dans ce
pays ils ont envie don qu'on leur parle
de leur fierté de tout ce qui fonctionne
il faut s'en emparer il faut que le
prochain candidat à la présidentielle
qui défend nos valeurs nos valeurs qui
nous réunissent aujourd'hui puisse
défendre ses métiers c'est très
important et je suis sûre que ça
contribuera à la victoire et puis enfin
je voudrais attirer votre attention sur
un problème plus
organisationnel au sommet de l'État il y
a un vrai un vrai problème on a affaire
à je vous l'ai dit plus de 200 métiers
220 si on ajoute l'art culinaire et en
fait ces métiers sont complètement
atomisé entre différents ministères il
n'y a aucune transversalité il n'y a pas
un ministre en fait qui comprenne ce que
c'est que l'excellence française moi je
préfère et je propose qu'il y ait
quelqu'un au sommet de l'État en tout
cas qui gère ceci d'une façon
transversale et qui s'occupe de faire en
sorte que le rayonnement de la France
trouve vraiment sa place alors je
voudrais finir en vous disant que si le
Vatican est à Rome la gastronomie les
métiers d'art l'excellence sont bien à
la France j'espère que je vous ai
convaincu et en tout cas je suis à la
disposition de chacun pour en parler
après merci à tous
merci alors le patrimoine pour le le
vivre il faut le il faut le le le
contempler il faut c'est c'est physique
et et quel lieu extraordinaire que que
Versailles pour vivre le patrimoine et
et le et le ressentir d'ailleurs je me
pose souvent la question aujourd'hui
dans une époque qui est parfois aussi
étroite d'esprit est-ce qu'on serait
encore en mesure de de faire Versailles
de faire ces grands établissements ces
grands monuments on trouverit forcément
un bout de plante protégée ou une espèce
de grenouille en disparition qui nous
empêcherait de toucher au site ceci
étant monsieur le le maire est-ce que
vous pouvez revenir sur le le
rayonnement de de de
versaill merci beaucoup d'abord toutes
mes excuses je suis en retard parce que
j'accueillis l'équipe de foot d'Irlande
ah voilà à versaill aussi une forme de
patrimoine euh
oui écoutez donc je prends le train
route moi j'aimerais faire deux
observations d'abord je pense que nous
avons vécu un tournant dans la politique
culturelle dans ces trois dernières
années il faut en être conscient la
politique culturelle c'est la fierté de
la France on est reconnu dans le monde
entier toujours comme le pays qui a
incarné la politique culturelle et
cetteque culturelle elle est née
d'ailleurs autour du patrimoine on
remonte au 19e siècle la création
d'inspection générale des monuments
historiques 1830 les grandes lois 1913
1930 nous avons donc si vous voulez une
culture très forte et qu'est-ce qu'on
vient de vivre en tant que parlementaire
je peux vous le dire on vient de vivre
une sorte de basculement qui nous a
beaucoup inquiété d'abord une baisse
brutale des dotations au patrimoine on
en a peut-être pas assez conscience
peut-être pas assez par parler mais ce
qui s'est passé en
2013-24 c'est une baisse des crédits au
patrimoine extrêmement importante une
baisse de 110 millions d'euros cette
baisse elle n'a jamais été rattrapée
depuis vous aviez entendre dire que le
budget 2016 était remarquable pour la
culture c'est un artifice comptable il
faut être conscient parce que on a
intégré ce qui était la redevance pour
les fouilles archéologiques qui
rapportaiit chaque année environ une
centaine de millions d'euros donc
aujourd'hui en réalité la baisse qu'on a
subi sur le patrimoine en 2013 2014 elle
reste la même et ça il faut en avoir
conscience parce que souvent on dit que
la droite n'aime pas la culture la
réalité c'est que la droite a fait
beaucoup mieux le 1 % culturel ça a été
un moteur pour la politique culturelle
en France il faut savoir que le 1 %
culturel on l'a atteint en 2011 en 2012
également en 2010 c'était la première
fois c'était qui au pouvoir pas de
commentairire aujourd'hui on est à
combien pour le budget culturel on est à
0,83 %. alors vous savez toujours la
gauche aura tendance à dire c'est nous
qui représentons la culture en France
dans la pratique il faut constater que
l'effort budgétaire était plus important
quand c'était la droite qui est au
responsabilités et ça on doit en avoir
conscience
et il faut également souligner que la
droite n'a pas sacrifié le patrimoine et
si demain nous revenons aux affaires il
faudra que nous soyons très fermes
là-dessus parce que la facilité c'est
toujours la même c'est de couper les
crédit du patrimoine le patrimoine ça
bouge moins il faut bien reconnaître
alors je défends je défends beaucoup
aussi l'art vivant je peux vous le dire
dans ma ville tout le monde le sait je
suis très engagé j'ai créé un festival
mais pour autant pour autant quand il y
a des coupes à faire ça doit pas être
systématiquement le patrimoine qui
trinque la loi de règlement là qui est
en cours c'est quoi on prend la baisse
uniquement sur les crédits du patrimoine
donc ça c'est le premier élément nous
n'avons pas à rougir ni du passé ni de
ce que nous allons faire alors ensuite
bien sûr vous avez entendu parler la loi
cap cette grande loi culturelle on nous
l'a tellement annoncé je vois
Jean-Pierre lelot on a beaucoup
travaillé ensemble lui au Sénat moi
l'Assemblée nationale dessus cette loi
elle était désastreuse dans sa première
mouture pour le patrimoine elle
remettait en cause les fondements mêmes
de la protection du patrimoine et
d'ailleurs vous en avez eu la preuve
Jacques l lui-même a dit cette loi faut
vraiment éviter et donc vous avez
soudain grâce aux multiples changements
de ministres ils ont pris conscience qu'
faisait une erreur historique et donc on
est revenu à l'Ancien Régime à peu près
à l'ancien système celui qui exist mais
voyez bien qu'au fond la perception
initiale de ce ministère elle était
assez désastreuse pour le patrimoine et
c'est surtout grâce à mobilisation que
nous avons fait élu d'opposition et
surtout avec le monde du patrimoine
qu'on a pu revenir à un peu plus de
raison il reste toutefois une chose dans
cette réforme c'est les 500 m les 500 m
c'est la base à protection en France
quand vous avez un monument historque
vous avez une protection de 500 m autour
ça représente 6 % du territoire national
le principe jusqu'à cette loi qui va
être bientôt voté c'était que on
dérogeait au 500 m que par exception on
a inversé le principe maintenant la
règle c'est qu'on déroge au 500 m et que
l'on peut l'appliquer si on n pas dérogé
je vous dis pas ça va être pas simple et
tout ça repose sur les épaules de qui
les architectes des bâtiments de France
or les architectes des bâtiments de
France aujourd'hui ils en peuvent plus
donc voyez bien que cette loi qui a
l'air comme ça aujourd'hui de ne pas
avoir touché parce que grâce à notre
mobilisation il faut bien dire on est
revenu à quelque chose un peu plus
sérieux en réalité elle fragilise donc
nous avons vraiment aujourd'hui nous une
responsabilité c'est de revenir à une
tradition de protection qui a toujours
été efficace et qui a failli vraiment
être mis en péril au cours de ces
dernières années et ça il faut le dire
alors maintenant des propositions
concrètes parce que il faut être concret
première proposition à mon avis c'est le
1 % culturel il faut que la droite ait
le courage dire qu'elle a fait le 1 %
culturel et qu'elle refera c'est pas
plus que les autres ministères si on a P
de difficulté peut-être tous les
ministères sont amenés à baisser leur
crédit mais c'est certainement pas moins
ce que l'on vient de vivre pendant 3 ans
autre élément de réflexion qui me paraît
important c'est qu'il faut recréer un
mouvement de solidarité alors vous avez
une chose merveilleuse c'est journées de
patrimoine ça fait des années que je
propose moi que l'on utilise la journée
du patrimoine pour faire un tirage
spécial du lotau du patrimoine et que le
bénéfice de ce tirage spécial soit
alloué aux associations du patrimoine
via sans doute l'opérateur qui Mons le
président qui est la Fondation du
Patrimoine
parce que vous voyez bien qu'aujourd'hui
la chance de notre pays c'est d'avoir
des associations sur le terrain
extrêmement efficace et à travers ce
symbole François il va falloir conclure
c'est une proposition qu'on a déjà
retenu à l'unanimité en tout cas celle
que vous formul ok il se trouve que
c'est moi qui l'ai formulé depuis des an
mais mais je me permets d'expliquer
pourquoi je me permets également de dire
que ce qui serait intéressant
aujourd'hui on en a besoin c'est une
c'est de c'est cette attention au petit
patrimoine la Fondation du Patrimoine a
eu un rôle majeur et elle a lancé les
souscriptions aujourd'hui comment nous
arrivons élus locaux à défendre le petit
patrimoine c'est grâce à ses
souscriptions c'est un moyen très
efficace et je pense qu'on pourrait le
coupler je me tourne vers erriic qui
connait bien ces sujets là je pense
qu'on pourrait réfléchir à permettre que
le mesena soit un peu assoupli notamment
vis-àis des entreprises s'il pte sur
cette rénovation du petit patrimoine une
action vraiment ciblé je pense aussi
qu'il faut aujourd'hui être conscient
qu'il faut jamais opposer le patrimoine
du passé et le patrimoine que l'
construit al vous on a toujours parlé
des grands travaux les présidents
République s'illustrent à travers les
grands travaux il y a une chose qui a
été faite c'est le métro du Grand Paris
et le métro du Grand Paris permet de
faire les grand travaux demain à travers
lesgar voilà merci de cette conclusion
prospective proposition qui sera dans
notre projet les aujourd'hui il y a un
plafond de 0,5 % sur le les entreprises
pour donc le le mesena on proposera de
passer à 1 % pour les PME notamment pour
le patrimoine de proximité pour qu'il y
ait patrimoine il faut qu'au préalable
il y ait création et pour qu'il y ait
création lorsqu'on parle de patrimoine
bâti il faut qu'il y ait architecte donc
je suis très heureux de passer la parole
à Eric président de l'école nationale
supérieure d'architecture de
Strasbourg merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Maire j'ai j'ai peut-être un peu plus
parlé de patrimoine qui est aussi une de
mes anciennes fonctions que
d'architecture mais je vais essayé de
lire les deux c'est pour ma
transition en tout cas ce que je
voudrais dire c'est effectivement
confirmé très rapidement ce qui a été
dit sur la richesse économique que
représente le patrimoine toutes les
études du ministère de la Culture ne
cessent de le souligner environ impact
économique global 21 milliards d'euros
impact économique direct
je
crois 7 ou 8 milliards d'euros et en
valeur
ajouté 4,4 milliards d'euros ce qui est
très important seule valeur
ajoutée à l'inverse effectivement on on
note depuis 2013 une baisse de l'effort
budgétaire de l'État en matière de
patrimoine Nicolas Sarkozi quand il
était président de la République avait
affiché l'objectif 4 milliards d'euros
pour le patrimoine sur 10 ans pour
l'entretien des monuments historiques
sur 10 an cet objectif a quasiment été
tenu il était quasiment tenu à 400
millions d'euros par an aujourd'hui en
matière de restauration des monuments
historique et ça concerne effectivement
aussi la profession des architectes et
tous les métiers qui sont derrière on ne
dépasse pas on tourne autour de 320
millions d'euros et j'y ajoute le fait
que les grandes institutions culturelles
les grands musées les grandes
bibliothèques des établissements comme
Versailles ont été invités à boucler
leur budget en prélevant sur leur fond
de roulement c'est-à-dire que les
grandes institutions patrimoniales ont
payé elles-mêm la subvention de de
l'État et cela doit être noté
aujourd'hui beaucoup de très grands
établissements non plus de fond de
roulement et ne peuvent pas mener de
travaux d'investissement ce qui veut
dire que le patrimoine est redevenu
clairement aujourd'hui un marqueur un
marqueur différenciant une politique
culturelle de droite et une politique
culturelle de gauche alors quelles sont
nos perspectives dans ce domaine je
crois qu'il faut vraiment qu'une
politique future remette le patrimoine
au cœur des passions françaises et le
remett au cœur des politique publique
les Français respectent et aiment leur
patrimoine les journées du patrimoine le
montre le succès de la Fondation du
Patrimoine le montre il y a aussi on
doit en être conscient des signaux
inquiétants et des tendances sans doute
aggravées par le désengagement de de
l'État et au-delà par une forme de
désintérêt public il y a des phénomènes
d'abandon et de
mésusage on connaît tous la question de
destruction d'église parce que les
communes n'ont plus la possibilité de
les entretenir ou de travaux trop
importants qui mettent en danger les
bâtiments on connaît tous le désastre de
l'hôtel Lambert sur l'île Saint-Louis
trop de travaux sur le patrimoine c'est
trop de danger c'est-à-dire que il y a
quand même une vision du patrimoine qui
consiste à l'exploiter et à le
surutiliser et en le faisant on le
détruit on détruit la richesse
économique qu'il porte la question nous
est vraiment posée jusqu'où aller dans
l'usage et dans l'instrumentalisation je
je donnerai un autre exemple la
polémique actuelle et je veux V pas
mettre en C qui que ce soit autour du
musée Laurin à Nancy sa modernisation en
cours ou la volonté de le moderniser
détruirait une écurie du 18e siècle et
l'injection de béton sous le sol du du
du musée détruirait les couches
archéologique et mettrait l'ensemble du
bâtiment en danger je rappelle que à
Laquila en Italie quand le tremblement
de terre a eu lieu le les dommages
causés au monuments et aux églises ont
été terriblement aggravés par le fait
qu'on les avait fortifiés avec du béton
je vous renvoie surtous ces sujets à des
médias comme la Tribune de l'Art animé
par Didier rckner ou aux articles très
nombreux de quelqu'un comme Alexandre
gadick voilà il y a quand même tout un
tout un ensemble de personnes qui
défendent le patrimoine avec beaucoup de
vivacité qui tiennent un peu le registre
de tout ce qui est en train de se passer
il y a aussi un phénomène de
méconnaissance faut vraiment qu'on
synthétise parce que j'ai encore deux
intervenants et je tiens à ce qu'il
puissent exprimer avant le le le
discours de clôture voilà jeis juste
dire un mot des des musées les Français
ne fréquentent pas assez leur musées
j'habite à Strasbourg les musées de
Strasbourg qui sont magnifiques sont
vides je vais pour mon travail à Dresde
le musée de dres est bondé il y a un
sujet comment amener nos nos jeunes
notre population vers nos musées qui
sont d'une richesse inoui enfin
puisqu'il s'agit de parler de
d'architecture je voudrais effectivement
dire je pense exactement la même chose
de que François de maère de la loi cap
le patrimoine ne doit pas venir à
travers cette question de périmètre des
abord une variable d'ajustement de la
transition énergétique et de la volonté
au nom de la de la transition
énergétique de densifier les villes
densifier les villes c'est très bien
mais encore une fois pas en sacrifiant
les abords il y a au contraire un usage
du patrimoine et là je parle du
patrimoine non classé du 19e siècle en
particulier qui est très important en
France là où je je travaille j'assiste à
de très beaux exemples de réhabilitation
de vieille casernes de vieux hitaux de
vieilles écoles par des bailleurs
sociaux notamment dans l'Est de la
France bâtigère avec le soutien de la
Caisse des dépôts et conciliation et nos
écoles nos écoles ils sont associé à
titre expérimental il y a énormément
d'expérience de construction de
logements sociaux dans de vieux
bâtiments qui permettent à des
populations qui qu'on qu'on installe
dans des logements sociaux d'habiter en
centre-ville dans des dans un patrimoine
réhabilité pour elle et ça tranche avec
la construction de logements sociaux qui
se
ressisation et ça
alors là et je voudrais juste conclure
en disant que les architectes sont tous
extrêmement intéressés par cette grande
thématique qui pourrait émergé
aujourd'hui bâtir dans l'existant
magnifique conclusion merci Bruno
rilavolet ancien directeur général lu
ppidou qui a notamment beaucoup exprimé
d'idées pertinentes sur le partage des
données numériques culturell juste un
chiffre aussi sur les œuvres puisque j'y
pense il y a d'après le ministère de la
culture dans les 23 frques 26000 œuvres
aujourd'hui nous nous proposons que ces
œuvres elles soient obligatoirement
exposées dans les mairie dans les lieux
publics c'est au cœur de notre projet
aussi ce patrimoine est totalement
inutilisé et et d'ailleurs on demande
aussi la transparence sur les modes
d'acquisition de ces œuvres et notamment
au regard des des peintres actuels voilà
pardon numérique entre
autres alors ancien directeur du du
Centre Pompidou mais aussi actuellement
président d' un festival de musique le
festival des forêts qui commencera le 21
juin il se passe dans les forêts de
Compigne un
écureuil c'est le festival qui est
applaudi mais aussi Nicolas Sarkozi je
croiszy
allez-y allez-y bien donc dans dans ce
festival on a le patrimoine naturel
celui des forêts
on a le patrimoine bâti celui des
églises abayes et puis on a le
patrimoine de la musique classique car
le patrimoine ce ne sont pas que les les
châteaux alors c'est important de parler
de la définition du patrimoine à mes
yeux le patrimoine c'est bien sûr
l'accès à nos racines mais c'est aussi
ce qui nous réunit et c'est le choix des
vivants c'est très important de dire que
le patrimoine c'est une chaîne qui relie
des vivants génération après génération
parce que chaque génération réinterprète
le patrimoine en fonction de ses propres
besoins le patrimoine ce ne sont pas que
les pierres on l'a beaucoup dit au tir
de sa table je n'y reviens pas mais une
chose me frappe c'est qu'on a trop
tendance à sectoriser et la réflexion
sur le patrimoine culturel ne devrait
pas être aussi étanche par rapport à
celle sur le patrimoine naturel sur les
espèces protégées le patrimoine paysager
le patrimoine urbain tout cela est relié
et quand on est en picard comme moi et
bien on constate que les cathédrales
sont magnifiquement préservées mais le
grand paysage de plaine qui les a fait
émerger lui il est saccagés c'est un
sujet de réflexion quelle conséquence
tirée de ce que je dis en ici à grand
trait et bien d'abord une chose
importante je crois puisque le
patrimoine c'est ce qui relie ce qui
réunit dans sa fonction de socle de lien
avec nos racines le patrimoine doit
parler à tous il faut donc penser dans
la France d'aujourd'hui le patrimoine en
fonction de la composition sociologique
et des
origines géographique réel de la
population du pays chacun doit pouvoir
retrouver ses paires les racines de la
France ce n'est pas une carotte les
racines de la France c'est un système
radiculaire avec bien sûr une grosse une
énorme branche chrétienne évidemment ou
plutôt judéo-chrétienne mais aussi des
branches indo-européennes greces latin
sel Fran et Germaine et aussi des
branches qui vont vers l'Afrique le
Maghreb d'autres pays du monde par
exemple dans le château de chanteillli
il y a la plus ancienne photo du port
d'Alger prise au 19e siècle comment
faire pour que cette photo devienne
iconique la contribution du patrimoine à
la cohésion sociale en France y
gagnerait donc cette à côté de
cette dimension dans la façon de
regarder le patrimoine je voudrais
rapidement euh dire trois
choses qui sont en fait des propositions
tout d'abord le patrimoine c'est une
politique publique et je suis de l'avis
que cette politique public ne s'est pas
assez modernisé quand on la compare à
d'autres politiques par exemple pour le
contrôle de la qualité des aliments que
nous mangeons et bien les vétérinaires
sont souvent dans les abattoirs et ce
que fait l'état c'est contrôler que les
vétérinaires font bien leur travail dans
les abattoirs et puis on doit aussi
avoir différentes catégories de
patrimoine dans le domaine des hôtels ou
dans le domaine des château des vins on
a CIN ou six catégories en fonction de
la qualité des vins ou dans le
patrimoine ça devrait être en fonction
des enjeux il faut apprendre à mieux
différencier les protections les règles
administratives en fonction des qualités
des catégories de patrimoine et à les
contrôler de la manière qui convient la
deuxième chose à propos du patrimoine
numérique c'est de dire que les plans de
numérisation c'est très bien mais c'est
le plus important c'est la diffusion de
ce patrimoine numérisé et cette
diffusion les instru institution en font
un peu mais le plus gros sera fait par
des tiers donc si on veut diffuser le
patrimoine numérique la la
proposition l'objurgation à tous les
acteurs culturels doit être faite des
licences licencier votre patrimoine à
des tiers et là il sera diffusé enfin la
question du financement étant essentiel
j'appelle la création d'un compte
satellite de la culture dans la
comptabilité nationale française
l'inventaire des financements n'est pas
bien tenu le suivi de l'évolution de ces
financements n'est pas bien tenu il faut
qu'on sache combien d'argent venant de
l'État certes des collectivités
territoriales des fondations du public
des entreprises arrivent dans les
différents domaines de la culture on a à
l'air numérique tous les moyens de
connaître l'argent qui va dans la
culture euh ainsi que l'exige la façon
dont nous l'aimons merci très très belle
intervention
synthéthique dernier intervenant
monsieur le président euh avant qu'il y
ait patrimoine je le disais tout il faut
qu'il y ait création et pour qu'il y ait
création il faut qu'il y ait créateurs
et pour qu'il y ait créateur il faut que
ces créateurs puisse vivre de leur
création et pour cela il faut rencontrer
la il faut favoriser catalyser la
rencontre entre la création la diffusion
la distribution parmi les grands acteurs
de cette rencontre il y a rid readid
Midem qui organise entre autres le MIP
TV le MIPCOM et le Midem sur
l'audiovisuel la télévision le contenu
des programmes et la musique son PDG
avec nous c'est Paul Zil et Jan sré en
lui donnant la parole merci merci
Monsieur le Maire j'aimerais bien
commencer en saluant m mes collègues de
l'industrie de la musique de la France
parce que on vient de de revenir tous de
de can où nous avons fêé le 50e
anniversire de Midam et américain
francophone vous pouvez encore
l'applaudir s'il vous plaît
merci juste juste pour me crédibiliser
il faut que je vous dise que mon épouse
elle est
françaiseit plus que 20 ans que j'habite
en France voilà voilà euh je ne sais pas
si vous le savez ou pas mais il y a il y
a les festivals qui sont très très très
visible mais il y a aussi les les salons
pour les professionnels et là ils sont
des lieux de de rencontrre d'échange de
de de trading de des affaires qui sont
concrétisées à travers les les
professionnels les les créateurs les
distributeurs euh au niveau
international et et nous à qu nous avons
le le bonheur d'organiser les événements
depuis plus que 50 ans donc 52 ans pour
notre salon le plus ancien dans dans le
secteur de la télévision
oui moi non plus moi non plus euh et là
c'est c'est j'ai j'ai le le privilège de
de d'avoir un visibilité je dirais
mondiale sur les industries de la
musique ainsi que la télévision et je
peux vous dire que c'est important pour
pour deux trois raisons la première
chose c'est que ces événements sur plan
sur le plan économique il génère pas mal
beaucoup de de impact économique sur
l'économie euh en France
euh l'impact direct et indirect et puis
il y a beaucoup de de de de travail
derrière beaucoup de de postes de
travail euh qui qui sont concernés mais
aussi le le le business de culture est
est très important vous le savez au
niveau mondial et et là avec avec la
présence de de les dizaines de pays je
peux vous dire que pour la
France ce qui se passe dans dans nos
événements euh en France c'est très
important pour pour les l'industrie
français pour les industries français
euh dans la télévision et la musique et
et et je je je demande le les politiques
de de de soutenir surtout euh nos
industries français parce que on a
besoin de ça parce que il y a un vraie
concurrence dans le je dirais le marché
de de de culture au niveau international
et dernière chose il y a vraie
opportunité aussi pour aller plus loin
euh vous vous connaissez tous le le
festival de filman mais j'aimerais bien
juste vous dire que il y a aussi une une
opportunité qui qui va se présenter
bientôt le le monde de la télévision
évolue rapidement aussi et il n'y a pas
espèce de de de plateforme ou vecteur
pour pour célébrer au niveau mondial
euh la qualité et l'émergence de de de
la télévision et et je je crois que
c'est une vraie opportunité pour pour la
France et il faut que soit ça soit en
France on est connu nous sommes connus
pour les festival pour les grandes
rencontres pour pour les fêtes pour la
reconnaissance de l'industrie de la
créativité le french touch il faut y
aller jusqu'au
bout et les affaires marchent bien avec
la culture merci merci cette synthèse
rapide je rappelle que les événements
organisés par po sont les leaders
mondiaux dans leur secteur d'activité
avec plus de 120 pays représentés
monsieur leés Président vous auriez bu
toutes les paroles qui ont été
prononcées tant la culture était au cœur
de nos préoccupations et quelle fierté
quand même et quel bonheur que
d'affirmer ici avant de vous donner le
micro euh la le fait de voir la culture
au cœur d'un projet d'alternance du
premier parti de l'alternance est une
spécificité des républicains que nous
vous devons et je tiens à vous en savoir
gr merci à vous le
dire